.
THANKSOR BEING WITH US
TONIGH
LET'S G RIGHT TOY OPEN.
TH WLD IS A LESS SAF PLACE
TODAY TH IT WASHE DAY JOE
BIDEN TOOK OFFE.
THAT'SECAUSE BIDEN I
NOTRANSPARENT, ISLATANTLY
DIONEST AND IS LITERLY
DANGEROUS.
BIDEN PRIORITES AFGNSITH
NO CONNECTION T THE UNITED
STATES AND NO VETTING OVER
AMICANITIZENS.
10 AFGHAN EVACUS ARE BEING
INVEIGATED FOR POSBLE TIES
TO TERRISM.
TH WORLD WATCHES AS BIDENACCORDS
AFGHAN MEN WITH CHILD BRIDE
PEDOILIA OR HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WHERE I COME FROM INTOISCONSIN
WHERE THEY ARE ANDONED, STRAND
AND LEFT AS HOSTAGES.
JOE BIDEN HAS GIVENERRORISTORGA.
NOT ONLY THAT, WE ARMED THEM TO
ACCOMPSH THEIR MISSI.
AS HE TRIES TO SL US L AFTER
LIE, THE AMERICAN PEOPL ARE
SEEING RIGHT THROU IT.
51% AN'T BUYING IT.
HIS APPROL RATG CONTINUES TOGO .
AND 60% DISAPPROVEF HIS
HANDNG OF AFGHASTAN.YOU SEE, JO.
YO HAV BEENYING FOR MONTHS
ABOUT AFGHASTAN.
ABOUT YOUR NON-DECIONS, AND
WHAT YOURILITARY CHIEF HAVETOLD.
IT'S ALL LIE AND DGEROUS ONES
AT THAT.
YOU A NO LONGER THE
COANDER-IN-CHIEF.YOU ARE THE LI.
YOU SPEW LS A TRU.
EN TURN AND BOBE AWA
INPABLE OF ANSRING
QUTIONS.
INSTEAD YOU SEND OUT YOU
PUPPETS ON A STRING TO DOUBLE
DO ON YOUR LIES.
YOUR BEHAVIOR I NOT ONLY A
DERELICTION OF DUTY AND YOUR
SWORN OH TO PROTECT AND DEFENDTL
OFHE UNITED STAS.
YO AID A ABETTED THE ENEMY WE
FOUGHTOR 20 YEARS WITH
AMERICANLOOD AND TREASUR
WHILE YOU TRY TO RESTRT OUR
COND AMENDMENT RIGHTS IN THE
HOMELAND, YOU LEAVE THE ENEMY
WITH BILLION O DOLLARS OFHE
MOSTOPHISTICATED MILITARY
EQUIPMENT I THE WORLD.
YOU EVAATED BAGRAMIR BASE
AND ALLOW THE TALIB TO
LEASE THEIR SO-CAED ENEMIES
ISIS-KEAVING OUR MILITAR TO
BE SITNGUCKS A THE KABUL
AIRPOR
13 SERVI MEMBERS RETURNED HOME
IN CASKETS BECAUSE YOU H T
ENEMONTROLLING WHAT LITE
PERIMETE THERE WAS.
YOUR COLDNCONCERNED BOREDOM AS
YOU REPEATEY LOOKED AT YOURWATCA
DIUSTING DPLAY OF YOUR
ANUS AND YOUR IBILITY TO
CARE ABOUT ANYBODY BY YOURSELF.
YO HA THE GALL TO CALL THE
EXIT AN ERAORDINARY SUCCE?
>> IT'S TIMEO LOOK AT THE
FUTURE NOT THE PAS
THE EXTRADINARYUCCESS OF
THIS MSION WAS DUE TO THE
INEDIBLE SKI, BRAVE AREOU
AND SELFLESS COURA OF THE NEWS
MITARY AND OUR DIPLOMATSND
INLLIGENCE PROFESSIONA.
JUE JEANINE: LR.FOR 18 MONTHS BR
CHAOTIC ENTRANCE O THE WORLD
STAGE, NOT ONE AMERICA WASSTUCHW
BECAE THEY KNEW DOND TRUMP
WOULD RESND.
>> FOR8 MONTHS N ONE
ERICAN SOLDIERAS KILD.
THAT W BECAUSE OF T
AGREEMT.
WEAD A VERYTRONG AGREEMENT.IT W.
ERE WERE MY OTHERARTS OF
E AGREEME, ALSO,F THEY
VIOLAT THEM, WEENT IN AND
BOMBED THE HELLUT OF TM.
DGE JEANE: JOE, YOU CAN'T
SHINEONALD TRUMP'S SHOES.HE WASU
E MEANING OF PEACE THROUGHSTREN.
YOU CSED CHAOS THROUGH
INCOMPETENCE.
YOU DIDN'T HAVE THE SPINE, THE
BRAINS OR THE CAPACITY TO KNOWWG
IT'S TIME F YOU TO GO BACK TO
THE BASEMENT WHERE YOU CAN WALK
OUND.
U BOTCH EVERYTHG.
YOU SHOD BE ASHAMED OF
YOSELF.
YO ARE NOT OY A LIAR, YOU ARE
A WEAK FKLESS INDIVIDUAL WHOSECA
AND AMERIN FAMILIES DEMAND
IMACHMENTESIGNATION AND A
COT-MARTIAL.
HERE IS ANOTHER LIE.
>> I WILL NOTONDUCT A HASTY
RUSH TO THE EXIT.
WEL DO IT RESPONSIB,ND
SAFE.THERE IS A HOME FOR YOU I .
AND WE'LL STAND WITH YOU JUS AS
YOU STOOD WITH US.
IF THERE ARE AMERICAN CITENS
FT WE'LL STAY UNTIL WE GET
THEM OUT.
ANY AMERICAN WHO WTS TO COME
HOME,E'LL GET Y HOME.
JUDG JEANINE: LIAR
HODARE YOU PUT AMERINS FROM
E HANDS OF TALIBAN A ISIS.
HOW DARE YOU ALLOWMPTY PLANES
TOLY BACK TO AMERICA.
WHANADIAN YOU SEARCH FOR
AMERICANS LIKE OTHER COUNTRIES
DID FOR THEIR PEOE.
HOW DARE YOU HAVE YR STATE
DEPAMENT THREATEN PRIVATE
ORGAZATIONS TRYING TO RETURN
AMERICANSND THEIR AFGHAN
ALLIES HOME.
>> I JUST LEARNED MULTIPLE
ATTEMPTS HAVE BEEN BRUSHED OFF.
THEY ARE NOT INTERESD IN OUR
LISTS MUCH.S. CITIZENS TRYINGTOI
R LIST OF U.S. GREEN
CARDHOLDERS.
>> THEY WERE BEHIN THE 8ALL
THE ENTIRE TIME.
WHEN I HEAR FRO AND ONE BLINKEN
AND JAKE SULLIVAN TYEND TO
PEAT THE LIES OF THE
ADMISTRATION THE MOS
I CY THE STATE DARTMENT HAS
AOT TO ANSWER FOR.
>> I BIEVE THEY WERE CAUGHT UP
IN THAT.
AT THEY DID PLAYING POLITIC
>> YOU DON'T KNOW WHO SHUTOU
DOWN FM LANDING.>> I DON'TNOW WN
T I BIEVE IT WAS 100%
DIRECTED FROHE STATE
PARTMENT.>> JOE, AREOU REAL I A
AMERICAN?
I D'T KNOW OF A LEADE W
WOULD LEAVE AMERICANS BEHIND AND
BRING IN UNVTED AFGNSITHCHILD BR
LAWS.
YOU EXPECTED THEORLD TO
APAUD YOU FOR ENDING THELONGESTU
THGHT SEPTEMBER* WOULD BE
ABOU YOU.
DEPTEMBER 11 WOULD BE AUT
U.
YOU ARE RHT.
BECAUS ANY ASSAULT ON THE
HOLAND WILL BEUE TO YOU AND
YOUR INEPTITUDE.
THAT'SY OPEN.